hallor sind auch immer bei der Arbeit ja
natürlich ja ja kann ganz gut arbeiten
gehüber da drüben haben wir unseren
wellnnessbereich
eingerichtet so machen wir das D nehme
ich das einfach mit und stell das da in
die Nähe das noch geklaut wird hier in
den einfachen hot ich
GLB hast gesehen noch nicht das ist gut
ja dann kennst du nicht unsere
Eingangsfrage nein ich hab mich gar
nicht vorbereitet alte Sau hat nichts
gemacht wir haben eine Standardfrage am
Anfang weil sich daraus immer die
gleichen Fragen sind egal W frag und die
erste Frage die ist auf jeden Fall immer
die gleiche wie ist die
Lage persönlich oder in der Welt das
kannst du beantworten wie du möchtest
persönlich
sehr angenehm sehr ausgeglichen eine
Woche Köln eine Woche am Stück im
gleichen Hotel eine Woche nicht Reis
müssen wundervoll die Weltlage schwierig
mhm wie kann man als Rampensau
ausgeglichen sein gar nicht eigentlich
es war eigentlich die klassische
Standardfragen
eingangslüge mit der ich immer einsteige
um so eine heile Welt vorzugaukeln nein
letztlich ist man natürlich permanent
unter Strom hektisch und und
und am gucken und am arbeiten und das
das ist natürlich so also ich habe
vorhin schon wieder gemerkt als ich
frühstücken war ich bin eigentlich
nervös geworden als ich da schon 12
Minuten vor meinem croisson saß und
dachte verdammt noch mal du hast immer
noch nichts gemacht heute gut ich glaube
jetzt nichts von all dem ehrlich nein ja
wirklich Z Minuten muss ich aufstehen
musst du hochgehen Computer hochfahren
Mails checken Mails beantworten mich
über die Nachrichtenlage updaten hat das
mit deinem Beruf zu tun also auch so wie
du deinen Beruf ausübst dass du da immer
am Puls der Zeit sein musst ja ja ja
sonst sonst geht es nicht also ich
arbeite ja nun wirklich aktuell und dann
das macht man entweder ganz oder gar
nicht das heißt entweder man ist
wirklich permanent äh auf auf
Themensuche und unterwegs und guckt was
passiert was geht ähm oder man muss es
bleiben lassen und sagen na ja ich spiel
es halt so runter das Programm und äh
ansonsten lass ich mir tagsüber gut
gehen und um 15 Uhr kommen die Mädels
aufs Zimmer gut ähm aber trotzdem bevor
wir über die Mädels reden sehr
interessantes Thema ähm das heißt wenn
man abends in dein Programm geht hört
man auch Sachen die man vielleicht über
die man schon gelesen hat tagsüber
absolut äh ich sage
Kabarett machen Kabarettist sein heißt
auf Ballhöhe sein das heißt abends ist
das Thema was tagsüber aktuell war das
geht nicht jeden Tag weil es gibt auch
Tage da ist einfach Flaute aber es geht
mindestens jeden zweiten und ähm es geht
mindestens mit den Themen die einmal
komplett durch die Tagespresse gegangen
sind aber es gibt ja undankbare und
dankbare ich sag mal Opfer
wahrscheinlich wie weit geht dann die
beishßhemmung nein die ist nicht die ist
nicht wirklich da weil das so läuft ja
auch das Geschäft nicht aber es ist ja
heute sozusagen state of the art dass
man sich als Prominenter auch wahnsinnig
drüber amüsiert dass man äh parodiert
wird dass äh man sich
dass es Prominente gibt andere
Prominente Kabarettisten die sich überin
lustig machen das gehört ja schon fast
zum Geschäft dass man das toll findet ne
das macht schon fast das
kabarettistische Geschäft wieder
schwerer weil es eben so ein so ein Usus
ist haha jetzt bin ich dran also die die
die letzten die sich darüber aufregen
sind dann sind
Leute wie Jürgen klensmann wo man dann
sagt das ist natürlich ganz peinlich wie
er dann nervös wird und sich über eine
wirklich witzige Karikatur in in der Tat
so aufregen kann ne aber ansonsten hört
man ja da nichts ne insofern gibt's auch
keine beishhemmung und man hat auch
keine Chance in die Presse zu kommen
durch irgendein Gag weil sich niemand
mehr nein das skandall Level liegt
unendlich hoch ne das ist so und im
Grunde genommen kann man fast sagen das
ist eigentlich Niklas lumann
Selbstreferentialität geh in die ist das
Sozi Philosopie Soziologie Soziologie
Philosophie und beides noch mal hoch
zwei okay okay die Meta Meta Meta eben
genau und das ist aber eigentlich ist
das Luma Selbstreferentialität des
Mediums es ist sozusagen man befindet
sich im Grunde in diesem
Unterhaltungsbereich ganz schnell in
einem in einem in einer luftleeren
Parallelwelt ne man kann alles sagen man
kann alles machen es stört keinen
es interessiert die Betroffenen nicht
die da irgendwie ähm ähäh äh
verarscht werden oder über die man sich
lustig macht oder über die man Poen
schreibt im besten Falle interessiert es
das Publikum und das ist natürlich auch
das eigentliche Ziel warum man es macht
aber das den den Skandal oder so zu
erzeugen das war früher sicher ähm
einfacher das geht heute eigentlich nur
noch mit mit Missverständnissen ich habe
in meiner SWR Sendung in der letzten
habe ich eine Nummer gemacht ähm wo ich
einen Fernsehreporter gespielt habe der
immer noch vor den Schulen des Landes
steht weil er wartet dass wieder einer
einer austickt wie in Winnenden ne war
eine böse medienti also da könnte schon
eine Grenze das war eine ganz böse
medienatiere daraufhin habe ich aber von
Zuschauer ganz viel böse Post bekommen
die sich böse beklagt haben aber das
waren natürlich Leute die da emotional
nah am Thema waren und auch nicht
erfasst haben um was es geht ne es war
mit keinem Wort eine eine
opferverhöhnung oder eine
täterüberhöhung sondern es war eine ganz
klar hochpräzise ausgearbeitete
Mediensatire das kann man dann da ist
dann schon da merkt man hey guck mal da
ist doch sozusagen wie wellbeck gesagt
hat
drücken Sie den Finger in die Wunde und
drücken sie schön fest zu was er ja auch
bei sich ausmacht holbeck ist ja ein
kurz zur Erklärung Autor Belgier
Elementarteilchen wo es wirklich ans
Eingemachte geht ist keine Satire
aber aber schon sehr lustig auch also
ich kenne viele Leute die das nicht
verstehen die die nicht lustig finden
ich finde es über über Strecken grandios
komisch und sehr lustig erzählt also
aber auch unglaublich traurig sowohl als
auch wie wie häufig in in in guten in in
guten künstlerischen Werken wo das wo
Tragik und Komiker sehr nah beieinander
sind bist du so Künstler wie er weil er
sagt ja man muss anderen Leuten weh tun
ihnen schaden man muss das alles mal
gemacht
haben um daraus schöpfen zu
können nein also S gehe ich nicht ich
habe für mich war dieses ich habe von
ihm gelesen es gibt ein einen frühen
Aufsatz von ihm Ende der 90er als er
noch vor allem Gedichte geschrieben hat
der heißt lebendig bleiben ein Leitfaden
und liegt bei mir auf dem Nachttisch ja
bei mir auch das ist natürlich ganz ganz
groß also das war das ist für mich
wirklich sozusagen mit der Zeit eine
eine schon sowas wie eine eine
kabarettistische Bibel geworden es ist
maßlos übertrieben was er schreibt äh
und es ist natürlich ähm nicht eins zu
eins zu nehmen aber sehr viel Wahres
drin sehr sehr sehr viel Wahres drin
kann ich nur jedem empfehlen der in
irgendeiner Form wie auch immer glaubt
er müsse kreativ arbeiten das ist
eigentlich sozusagen die Bibel wo man
sagt dass wenn man das mal gelesen hat
dann äh ist ist geht es eineem mit
vielen besser aber ihm geht's ja nicht
gut dabei er sagt ja auch man es soll
einem gar nicht gut gehen ja ja er sagt
ja es darf elich gut gehen ja das wie
geht's dir denn dann
ähm also dir geht's richtig beschissen
also wenn ich absolut bes nein aber es
geht sagen wir mal so es ist glaube ich
eher sozusagen ich habe für mich
festgestellt es ist ähm das ein ein ein
lebendig bleiben durch Ambivalenz ne
also dass man
nie in dieser totalen Entschiedenheit
nicht in so eine Ruhe kommt in so ein
ach ich habe ja alles habe ja meinen
Platz dann gibt es sicher nichts mehr
was von außen als Impuls kommt es es
muss eine gewisse Unruhe da sein damit
etwas passiert ich finde nicht dass man
deshalb zwangsläufig unglücklich sein
muss aber
äh natürlich äh ich habe in meinem
Programm z.B festgestellt ich habe eine
Nummer im Programm im aktuellen
wo ich so ein bisschen erzähle wie es in
im im im kleinkunstverein zugeht ne und
was da passiert ne wo ich so ein
bisschen auch diese kamerettszene zeige
was ist dann auch für eine was häufig
das auch für eine Selbstgefälligkeit ist
und dann mache ich so den
kleinkunstvereinsvorsitzen der eine
Ansage macht und das es und sich
dainstellt und es auch nicht kann und
auch nicht will aber trotzdem macht und
sich aber darin toll findet und das ist
auch so eine szenensatire so eine so
eine
kabarettszenensatire und und das war
habe ich ja dre vi Jahre lang gespielt
diese kleinen Kleinkunstbühnen 100 Leute
und so war froh wenn da 40 saßen und da
sind diese Nummern entstanden weil ich
diese diesen diese Ansagen immer so
grauenhaft fand wenn da wieder einer
rausging und und ich wusste dir das
Publikum ist tot wenn du rauskommst weil
er hat sie platt gemacht weil er es
einfach nicht kann und es ist auch nicht
schlimm er muss es auch nicht können er
muss es nur einsehen dass er es nicht
kann und das war eine Zeit da ist das
entstanden für das jetzige Programm
jetzt bin ich aus dieser da raus aus
diesen aus diesen Läden wo ich auch
immer raus wollte weil ich es weil ich
immer größer spielen wollte und das
heißt jetzt fehlt schon mal die
Auseinandersetzung genau damit damit
fehlt schon mal ein Thema ne weil
sozusagen eine bestimmte Form von
Reibung nicht mehr da ist und bei
wellbeck kann man das ja besonders gut
sehen der ja nun seit er dann auch immer
reicher wurde und und die Verlage
gewechselt hat und sich hat verkaufen
lassen und wieder einkaufen lassen und
je besser es dem Gen desto muss man
sagen desto schlechter wurde er leider
aber das ist nicht zwangsläufig so ich
glaube es geht drum
dass es etwas gibt was einen berührt auf
üt was ein beschäftigt dass es immer
schon immer wieder diese Phasen gibt wo
man auch nicht weiß wie es weitergeht
das ist für einen selbst ganz wichtig
aber das trifft eh Nietsche man muss
noch Chaos in sich haben um einen
tanzenden Stern gebären zu können mein
Gott wo hast du diese ganze ich sag mal
dieses philosophische Fundament her hat
dich das interessiert studiert studiert
ja ich habe se Jahre Philosophie
studiert oh gott hilft das oder stört
das sowohl als auch nein nein ich finde
es hilft also äh nicht unmittelbar also
nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwie äh ich
würde mich jetzt nicht auf die Bühne
stellen wollen und und Philosophie
erklären das nicht aber es hilft
weil man sich doch mit etwas beschäftigt
hat was außerhalb des des eigenen
Horizonts liegt den man sonst so
permanent beackert ne und weil weil man
vielleicht wenn man es entsprechend
angeht lernt Strukturen zu verstehen
Analogien herzustellen ähm auch eher
gegen den Strich denken lernt was ja für
den Kabarettisten ganz wichtig ist them
von der anderen Seite anzugehen sowas da
hat es mir extrem viel gebracht aber
äh jetzt nicht unmittelbar es eh so eine
Quelle es ist so ein immer wieder ich
lese bis heute sehr viel in der Richtung
und es ist immer wieder dann schön diese
diese Texte zu lesen und da abzutauchen
und zu sagen ich muss mich jetzt nicht
unbedingt nur mit Tagesgeschäft
beschäftigen ist das eine Art eine
Perspektive zu finden das auch ja auf
Dinge zu gucken ja absolut ja das stimmt
also das das ist so und die anders zu
sehen ganz genau und das ist äh dafür
bringt es dafür hat es mir sehr sehr
viel gebracht das werden mir sämtliche
philosophiepressoren der Republik übel
nehmen dass ich die Philosophie darauf
verkürze was ich aber nicht tue ich
verkürze es nur jetzt weil es jetzt um
um um zielgeführte Antwort geht ja okay
aber es schwebt ja immer schon die
meterbene bei dir mit ja natürlich das
ist ja sonst wär es ja langweilig ne das
ist ja da bin ich das ist
ja letztlich bin ich da postmodern das
ist ja immer die verschiedenen Ebenen
das ist das einzige was mich am Kabarett
interessiert also dass man wirklich
sozusagen verschiedene Ebenen herstellt
das Publikum verführt irritiert an
Gedanken aufbaut die Richtung wechselt
und am Ende das dann wieder
zusammenfügt das ist das was mich reizt
wo man einfach danach rausgeht wie ich
aus ein paar Programmen auch im
rausgegangen bin und danach gedacht habe
WoW das beschäftigt mich das das das
wirkt nach das ist damit mache ich jetzt
nicht gehe nicht raus und mache damit
Schluss weil der Abend ist vorbei
sondern irgendwie geht mir das nach ne
und das ist immer die Wirkung die ich
erzeugen wollte dass man im besten Fall
auch da ähm ambivalent oder aufgerührt
rausgeht und nicht so ah ja war lustig
was war da noch mal über was hat der
geredet weiß ich mehr also du willst ein
Ambivalenz der Widersprüchlichkeit die
Menschen sollen am Ende verunsichert
eher sein
als ich würde eher sowas wie sagen wie
wie wie wie irgendwie berührt oder oder
der das irgendwie was bleibt das wie
nach einem guten Gespräch wo man sagt
man geht nicht es gibt Gespräche da geht
man am sitzt man an der Bar unterhält
sich geht danach ins Bett und denkt sich
ja es war nett man hätte aber auch eine
Stunde früher gehen können ne aber hat
nicht geschadet schläft man Morgen eine
Stunde länger und es gibt die Gespräche
wo man danach rausgeht und denkt
Wahnsinn es war so toll es hat mir so
viele anstößse gegeben worüber ich jetzt
nachdenken will es jede Minute hat sich
gelohnt es hätte noch eine Stunde länger
dauern können aber dann gibt ja noch das
gute Gespräch was Nachwirkung hat was
Konsequenzen hat und es gibt das Gute
Gespräch
was zwar super ist aber es ist nicht
gemeint ja es ist einfach nur man hat
sich vielleicht intelligent unterhalten
man hat vielleicht ein wichtigen Punkt
ab angetoucht aber keiner zieht daraus
Konsequenzen weil er zu bequem ist ja ja
das ist natürlich das was ich nicht mehr
beeinflussen kann ich weiß ja nicht
welche Konsequenzen die die die Leute
aus dem aus dem Ziehen ich finde es auch
schwierig weil ich maße mir nicht an
sozusagen zu sagen das ist die
Konsequenz
so geht es so müsst ihr es machen das
kann ich nicht das wäre auch vermessen
das muss ja auch nicht sein aber ziehst
du denn Konsequenzen aus dem was du
verarbeitest wie lebst du ist was ist
dein Leben ist dein Leben dieser Beruf
oder gibt es bei dir zwei Bereiche
Privatleben und Beruf oder ist das so
ineinander verworben verwoben dass du es
nicht trennen kannst ich kann es kaum
trennen also es ist natürlich gibt es
privatbereiche aber es es fließt
letztlich alles da hinein
also alles was diesen Beruf ausmacht
fließt auch ins Private mit ein ist
nicht so dass ich jetzt permanent lustig
sein muss privat überhaupt nicht aber
es ist alles findet in diesem in diesem
Umfeld statt und
das ist auch nicht mehr man kommt ich
hab mir das lange vorgemacht ach so so
wie man das von den Clowns kannte auch
privat ganz traurig und ernst und ganz
anders aber es ist Quatsch es stimmt
nicht man übt privat man man man testet
privat Poen aus man lässt auf der Bühne
irgendwann mit einer gewissen
Entwicklung eine Nachdenklichkeit zu die
eigentlich sonst privat wäre aber es ist
letztlich fließt es ineinander also
alles andere ist auch Quatsch natürlich
gibt's eine Bühnenfigur die ist noch ein
bisschen anders als die Privatperson
aber es vermischt sich es vermischt sich
letztlich alles und es muss glaube ich
auch so sein also ich habe das immer das
habe ich mal gelesen bei bei bei Markus
Lippert de Maler der mal gesagt hat
meine Arbeit stand immer im tentrum das
wussten alle die mit mir gelebt haben ne
und das ist bei mir auch so
deswegen willst du keine dauerhafte
Partnerin das habe ich ja nie gesagt na
sagen wir mal so du hast dich ambivalent
Gehä nein das habe ich nicht ich habe
nur gesagt ich habe nur gesagt dass ich
nicht heiraten werde oder will und so
und diese und das nicht will diese
Institution nicht nicht meine ist wie
ich auch im Programm sage aber nein
dauerhafte Partnerschaften das ist ja
nicht aus geschlossen das ist ja nicht
äh das ist ja nicht so dass es ein Tabu
ist gar nicht aber könnst sie sowas
vorstellen äh Familie Kinder nein das
geht nämlich dann wahrscheinlich nicht
es ging schon viele Kollegen haben
bewiesen dass es geht das ist eine Frage
des Willens aber bei dir jetzt der Fall
wenn du sagst dass Beruf und Privatleben
soinander verknüpft sind ich sehe dafür
ich möchte das nicht ich sehe mich da
nicht in der Rolle ich möchte das für
ich sehe das nicht in meinem ich sehe
dafür im Moment keinen Platz in meinem
Leben vielleicht sehe ich das in 10
Jahren anders
so offen muss man sagen ich habe schon
für viele Dinge in meinem Leben keinen
Platz gesehen und plötzlich war er da
aber ich habe früher nie Sport gemacht
ich hatte einfach gesag geglaubt ich
hätte keine Zeit heute mache ich das
regelmäßig heute könnte ich gar nicht
mehr ohne oder ich habe lange in in als
ich studiert habe auf 23 Quadratmetern
gewohnt in einer Wohnung die die man nur
als Student mieten konnte damals in
Freiburg und di Jahre habe ich mich
damit beschäftigt wenn ich fertig bin im
Studium wie kann ich diese Wohnung
halten obwohl ich nicht mehr studiere ne
weil ich ich wollte nicht größer wohnen
ich rausgeschmissenes Geld ich wollte
ich wollte in diesem genau in diesem
kleinen Bereich auf 23 m mein Leben
verbringen und das irgendwann bin ich
dann deutlich größer geworden weil ich
es nicht mehr ausgehalten habe und
vorher habe ich es ausgeschlossen aber
dennoch ist beim Thema Thema Familie
Kinder ist bei mir so ich ich sehe da in
meinem Leben keinen Raum ich könnte das
nicht ausfüllen also ich könnte diese
Rolle nicht füllen und ich finde man
wenn man sowas macht dann muss man da
auch Zeit für haben sich widmen ich habe
dann sehr sehr großen Respekt vor Leuten
die das machen ich finde das eine
unglaublich große Aufgabe die ich sehr
respektiere man man muss aber man muss
schon da muss ich finde da gehört schon
eine Entscheidung dazu ein Wille eine
Lust das das zu machen und ich
habe nicht so großen Respekt vor so
Leuten die sagen na ja es passt nicht so
aber wir machen es halt mal weil ich
finde dazu ist die Verantwortung die man
dafür ein neues Leben übernimmt viel zu
groß und in meinem
Leben meine Energie findet auf anderen
Landstadt ja das das heißt deine
Partnerin ist immer mit den
Kabarettisten Florian Schröder zusammen
das ja letztlich ja also
nicht wie gesagt nicht so dass ich jetzt
permanent lustig bin aber
äh natürlich das ist äh das ist eine das
ist eine Form von von das ist eine Form
von Berufung ne und natürlich stellt man
auch mal ab aber letztlich ist alles was
ich wahrnehme alles was ich tue alles
was ich lese auch wenn ich mich im im im
Sommer im Urlaub hinsetze und und Hegel
lese
tue ich das letztlich irgendwie als
Kabarettist auch wenn ich natürlich den
nicht darauf hin lese dass ich ihn
morgen auf der Bühne verwerten will aber
insofern ist es ist das ist das so ja
aber es kann auch sein dass jemand am
Strand an dir vorbeiäuft und das kann
dann wieder ein Punkt sein wo du sagst
wo ist ein Stift wo ist ein Zettel ja
natürlich ja ja obwohl ich das
eigentlich gar nicht brauche ich merke
mir das ich mer mir das ich schreibbe da
gar nicht so viel auf ich merke mir das
dann und häufig äh ist es ganz
interessant nehme ich das in dem Moment
wo ich irgendwas verwertbares
warahrnehme äh das dann sehe ich das
aber nehme das nicht sofort auf oder ich
nehme es mit einem Blick auf
Verwertbarkeit hin war glaube aber sehe
in dem Moment noch gar nicht wie genau
das dann auf der Bühne steht oder was
daran dann lustig sein könnte oder wie
die wie das öffentlich zu machen wäre
sondern ich erzähle es dann einem
dritten später was mir passiert ist und
dann kommt der Moment wo ich es ohne
dass ich es will bühnenreif erzähle und
dann checke ich sofort es oh das
funktioniert funktioniert nicht und dann
denke ich so dann mache ich was dusus
ist diese Fähigkeit über dich gekommen
also war die von vorne rein da oder hast
du irgendwas aufgespürt und dann
entwickelt das war eigentlich
eigentlich da solange ich denken kann
also bewusst wurde es mir erst als ich
mich damit retten musste in der Schule m
war weil ich einfach keine Möglichkeit
hatte war sehr unsportlich und sehr dick
damals und musste irgendwas tun und da
hi half mir nur der Humor weil ich
anders auch nicht an an an Mädels rank
kam was natürlich mit 14 das vorräige
Ziel ist konntest du dich denn retten ja
ja ja darüber dann schon also dann dann
habe ich es eben über Humor getan da
wurde es mir zum ersten Mal sozusagen
bewusst dass es nach außen funktioniert
dass andere drüber lachen aber ganz früh
bei mir zu Hause bei meiner Mutter wurde
parodiert also wir haben uns auch
gegenseitig parodiert wenn es Krisen gab
W es wurden andere das war irgendwie das
war so von Anfang an irgendwie da auch
dieser dieser Drang nach außen zu gehen
irgendwie es lustig zu sein und und
m alles was man wahrnimmt irgendwie auch
auch lustig zu machen das das war von
Anfang an da ja und das
mit der Zeit hat man das natürlich
professionalisiert und kanalisiert aber
es war immer da kann man denn Krisen so
bewältigen mit Humor oder ich sag mal
hat sich schon mal eine Freundin von dir
getrennt weil die gesagt hat du kannst
nie ernst sein das ist jetzt nicht
witzig nein das war nur das war noch
nieer Grrund weil ich glaube ja dass ein
tiefer Ernst dazu gehört um um
überzeugend lustig sein zu können also
äh das ist absolut essentiell und das
merkt man auch ich glaube die großen
Komiker waren immer auch tiefernste
Menschen äh die auch auch wirklich äh
die Fähigkeit hatten ähm die Welt auf
einem gewissen Reflexionsniveau
wahrzunehmen äh man merkt das ganz
schnell ob diese ob da so ein ein
Fundament ist
eine oder ob das wirklich nur ist nur
klassenkown ne der ich auch war aber
das sind eben die Anfänge und auch
selbst der der wirklich gute klassenkown
ist schon wieder einer wo irgendwas
dahinter steckt und damit ist man wieder
bei wellb irgendeine Form von light ein
ein
ähm ein ein ein getrieben sein ein Thema
irgendwas ne ähm das merkt man und ich
finde immer ganz schrecklich wenn man so
äh das Gefühl hat da ist so da ist so
gar nichts ne weil ich glaube man
braucht diese andere Seite sonst ist
kann man auch nicht wirklich gut lustig
sein auf Dauer ist es so dass hinter
einem einer guten poante immer eine
tiefe Wahrheit steckt und ich sag mal
nur der sie wirklich gut verarbeiten
kann der sie begriffen hat ja das das
mag so sein aber man muss ganz klar
sagen in keinem bei keinem karettisten
dieser Welt ist das zu 100%
durchzuhalten man gibt immer dem Affen
Zucker irgendwann das heißt man macht
auch etwas wo man vielleicht gar nicht
verstanden hat man weiß das ist witzig
aber nee anders man hat es verstanden
aber man macht sozusagen den Witz oder
den Gag der eigentlich der der der der
weniger inhaltsstarke ist ne
als der den man verstanden hätte weil
man sich sagt ich will ja auch dass die
Leute was zu Lachen haben ne und dann
geht man eben auch auf auf
da wird dann eben auch mal ein GCK
sozusagen um seiner selbstwillen gemacht
realhumor das gibt's das gibt's bei
jedem kameratisten das gehört
wahrscheinlich auch dazu einfach weil
man auf auf ein Publikum verwiesen
bleibt ne also weil einfach weil
natürlich da Leute sitzen die sich
amüsieren wollen es ist dann nur eine
Stilfrage wo macht man es wie macht man
es und wie oft ne und es gibt Programme
die da ist es nur so und es gibt
Programme da macht man es ab und zu mal
und und dann hat es aber so versuche ich
es zu machen dann hat es eine Funktion
im Programm warum man es macht um dann
wieder die Leute auf eine andere Ebene
zu kriegen und wieder auch was was was
zu machen was jetzt nicht irgendwie Po
Mainstream ist ja es gibt ja nun
Comedians will ich auch gleich noch
Fragen oder Kabarettisten oder Komiker
was was du jetzt bist aber die die haben
wahnsinig viel Fernsehen zu machen und
da gibt's dann manchmal standups die
sind wirklich schrecklich dünn und aber
es gibt ein Gag da drin und der ist
meistens dass dass irgendjemand
beschimpft wird ja
ärgerst du dich dann über solche
Kollegen nein nein
nein ärgert man sich nicht wenn wenn
jemand aus der eigenen zumft etwas macht
wo man denkt mein Gott der hätte sich
doch mal anstrengen
können
nö ich ich der Gedanke liegt nah aber äh
ich denke dann meistens
m gut dass du es machst wenn die Leute
zu mir kommen dann sehen sie dass es
auch anders geht weil wenn wenn alle
wenn das keiner mehr machen würde
dann wä ja die Konkurrenz in meiner
Sphäre noch größer also dir würde es
nicht
passieren ein ganz dünner Text ja ein
ganz dünner Text eigentlich keine
richtige Pointe und weil nichts
funktioniert kommt dann eben sag mal
Beschimpfung also ich habe das mit
Sicherheit schon gemacht also ich könnte
man könnte jetzt sicher Nummern finden
wo ich gen das gemacht habe ich mit
Sicherheit aber ich würde jetzt mal
behaupten dass es heute anders ist dass
ich
heute glaube ich niemanden mehr wirklich
brachial beschimpfe das hat man am
Anfang gemacht um der Wirkung willen das
ist genaus so ein Thema das habe ich
auch gemacht am Anfang das gehört
wahrscheinlich über eine gewisse Etappe
auch dazu aber heute würde ich das
glaube ich nicht mehr machen wenn ich
habe hatte lange im Programm hab das
dann auch ausgenommen ich hatte lange im
Programm eine so eine so eine Passage wo
ich Kindergärtnerinnen wirklich
beschimpft habe also Erzieherinnen und
bewusst dann Kindergärtnerinnen gesagt
habe ne und und gesagt habe das ist
sozusagen ähm
Realschülerinnen die dann plötzlich äh
sich dazu aufschwingen
Kinder zu erziehen und
ähm wenn man mal auf der Realschule war
wie ich da weiß man welche ähm äh wie
habe ich gesagt welche ähm äh Tumpen
Retorten Girlies da vom Band fallen ähm
und die die sollen dann sozusagen die
dürfen dann die entscheidendsten Jahre
im Leben eines kleinen Kindes mitprägen
ne ähm und äh ich stehe da ist immer ein
gewisser Teil des Publikums aufgestanden
und rausgegangen ja und äh das war so
und ich stehe inhaltlich nach wie vor
dazu dass das häufig so ist äh und dass
es dieses Phänomen gibt man tut aber
sehr vielen da natürlich auch Unrecht
und ich habe das dann letztlich aus dem
Programm genommen weil ich es einfach
unfein fand und weil es einfach zu
zu mitm holzham zu sehr mitm Holzhammer
drauf ist also beim ich habe das immer
der Ky Lorenz vom komödchen hat dann
immer gesagt es macht Buff ne und man
ist wirklich so dass das dass das Opfer
der Satire nicht nur in den Sack stecken
sondern auch noch zumachen und
draufhauen und ich finde man muss
irgendwie die Opfer versuchen auch noch
leben zu lassen ne und nicht gleich
komplett zu töten und das war so eine
Passage also es ging mir da weniger um
eine inhaltliche zurücknah es hat war
auch nicht schlimm da das P es ging mir
auch nicht drum dass ich das Publikum
gespaltet habe das war okay es ging drum
dass es einfach dass ich dachte nee es
passt nicht zu deinem Stil es ist zu es
ist einfach zu brachial und das das ist
eine Phase da macht man das das möchte
ich aber eigentlich heute
nicht mehr
machen hat das damit zu tun wie du dich
selbst verstehst als da kommt jetzt
meine Frage bist du Kabarettist Komiker
Comedian es gibt ja heute irsinnig viele
Begriffe dafür was bist du ich bin
Kabarettist das sage ich mit werf und
Überzeugung auch weil es natürlich heute
in dieser Industrie dieser
humorindustrie ganz wichtig ist dass man
sich selbst in eine Schublade packt
bevor es andere tun ne okay deswegen
sage ich immer ich bin Kabarettist ich
bin das auch von der Arbeitsweise ich
bin das
thematisch wenn gleich ich das nicht
meine in der Distanz zur Comedy unter
dem Motto Comedy ist Bad ich will nichts
damit zu tun haben für mich liegt die
die Antwort darin heute äh satirischen
Humor zu machen ähm ein Thema zu haben
ein Anliegen zu haben ein ein etwas zu
haben was einen bewegt worüber man reden
will was irgend in irgendeiner Form auch
wenn das ein ganz blödes Wort ist was in
irgendeiner Form gesellschaftliche
Relevanz hat ähm ohne dass es diese
altbackene
äh besser Wisser die Welt ist schlecht
Haltung hat die das die dem deutschen
klassischen Kabarett lange vorgeworfen
wurde mir geht's da um mehr Leichtigkeit
ganz klar ohne dass die Leichtigkeit auf
Kosten der der inhaltlichen Tiefe geht
und ich behaupte dass das geht ein gutes
Programm ist oder auch eine gute
Sendung Unterhaltungssendung eine
kabarettsendung ist immer eine wo man
sich absolut pissen kann verlachen als
Publikum aber wo es eben auch mal
wirklich 5 Minuten wo auch mal 5 Minuten
Ruhe ist im Saal und man sagt so und wir
machen jetzt mal ein Thema auf und das
hört ihr euch auch mal an ohne dass es
eben gleich so die ihr seid alle ihr
seid alle schlecht und die Welt ist
schlecht und ich habe es eh seit langem
verstanden Haltung hat aber
kam das nicht auch aus einer diese
Motivation aus dem Selbstverständnis der
Kabarettisten heraus ich bin unzufrieden
mit dieser schlechten Welt ich will sie
verbessern und meine Methode ist die der
Satire was ist bei dir die Motivation
m die Motivation bei mir ist ich möchte
sozusagen auf die die Aporien die ich
sehe was sind Aporien bitte oh ja
stimmt PL schon wieder bin realsch
entschuldigung ich f gleich
runter auf sozusagen die aporierenden
ausweglosigkeiten oder auf die einfach
auf auf gewisse Punkte die ich sehe
aufmerksam zu machen da da sehe ich eine
einen ein ein Problem ein ein
Widerspruch ein ein ein Punkt der der
Unlösbarkeit oder auch der Lösbarkeit
oder da ist etwas an an ein einen
Schlusspunkt gekommen ähm oder dar da
das will ich das versuche ich zu zeigen
aber ohne ohne diesen was die was die
Satire ja auch die immer ausgemacht hat
war immer der Zeigefinger ne die Satire
war ja in der Gattung immer so die
Satire weiß es im Zweifel besser ne und
das
ähm behaupte ich von mir nicht ich weiß
es in vielem auch nicht besser ne ich
ich habe da so eine fassbinderhaltung
der immer gesagt hat ich weiß auch nicht
wie es geht ich kann nur sagen was ich
schlecht finde ne und
ich habe nicht ich habe kein Rezept ich
bin dafür letztlich würde ich mich darau
belastet fühlen weil ich bin dafür auch
zu jung ich bin nicht 50 ich bin nicht
60 ich kann einfach nur sagen ich
beobachte meine eigene Generation so man
von der überhaupt sprechen kann glaube
ich recht aufmerksam ich glaube die Welt
recht aufmerksam zu beobachten und es
zeigen sich Dinge ne wie jetzt in diesem
Programm wo ich mich mit dem Thema
Familie beschäftigge wo ich dann am Ende
ein plorier für die Scheidung halte und
sage die Ehe ist am Ende und versuche zu
begründen warum ich diese Institution
für ein für diese Generation die wir
sind oder für den Punkt an dem wir
stehen nicht mehr für die richtige und
nicht mehr für lebbar halte ne
m und
m das das ist letztlich der Punkt aber
das zentrale ist es muss einen Abend
lang lustig sein das darf deshalb kommen
die Leute das will ich auch ich möchte
die Leute lachen aber es muss eben auch
einen finde ich irgendwo was geben wo
man sagt ähm
äh da guckt zeigt man zeigt man
sozusagen die Wunde ne und sagt da bis
dahin und ich weiß auch nicht wie es
besser geht aber ich möchte darauf
aufmerksam machen und äh die äh bei
früheren das ist natürlich der
Unterschied zu zu dem was was die was
die früheren Generationen oder die jetzt
frühere Kabarettisten Generation die die
so übermächtig ist ne also
die jetzt 40 bis 60 zum Teil
70-jährigen was die natürlich hatten und
was sie auch ausgemacht hat und bis
heute ausmacht ist eine Ideologie die
waren immer links in der Regel fast alle
und von wenigen Ausnahmen abgesehen aber
das waren immer Leute die sich die
damals in irgendeiner Form AG Prop
gemacht haben oder irgendwie in dieser
Links autonomen Szene unterwegs waren
und die sich ein Leben lang an dieser
Ideologie bis heute abarbeiten können
das ist eine großeance das ist sehr
fruchtbar bei sehr vielen Kollegen
aber
es ist natürlich auch eine Bürde weil
man permanent sozusagen in diesem
letztlich ist es ja bei vielen
Kabarettisten ein ein
entfremdungsprozess letztlich von der
SPD ne was immer so der oder so die
Partei sagt ja das ist es und das ist
bei uns oder bei mir nicht mehr so wir
ich habe keine ich habe kein bin kein
Ideologe ich habe keine Ideologie ne
und ich komme nicht aus bestimmten
Richtung ne ich äh ich gehe da anders an
Themen ran ne und von daher habe ich
auch nicht den Überbau und nicht dieses
ähm dieses brechtsche wie es zu sein
hätte ne du hast die Philosophie ich hab
ja genau aber die weiß es ja weiß auch
letztlich auch ganz die Philosophie hat
ja letztlich auch keine Antworten die
stellt ja eigentlich auch nur wenn man
sie richtig liest eigentlich auch nur
immer neue Fragen ne und das gleiche ist
eigentlich kann ich auch nur tun ne ähm
und äh deswegen steht man dann auch oft
so fassungslos äh äh davor weil man sagt
was was sollen wir eigentlich noch
erzählen das war ganz lange mein Problem
am Anfang was soll ich eigentlich
erzählen jetzt inhaltlich was ist mein
Thema es ist alles gesagt ich muss
wahrscheinlich 50 werden um Kabarett
machen zu können ne aber es gibt doch
gerade jetzt immer wieder neue
Finanzkrise und eben Winnenden oder
schreckliche Ereignisse es gibt doch
genügend Punkte absolut das sehe ich
heute auch so aber lange habe ich das
nicht getan ne weil die Zeit auch anders
war ich sag mal unter Schröder klar da
war erm
aber es aber alle diese ganzen Themen
wie Finanzkrise das ist ja trotzdem
immer noch das hinterher hächeln der
Aktualität ne also man läuft da dann den
Themen hinterher das ist ja sozusagen
kabarettistisch nur eine Seite die ist
wichtig und die ist schön die macht Spaß
aber die andere Seite ist ja in einem
Programm ein grundlegendes Thema zu
finden ein Thema wo man das ist für z D
Jahre jetzt mein Thema und da hänge ich
hächle ich nicht nur dem Thema hinterher
dass ich nächste Woche wieder
rausschmeißen muss weil die nächste Sau
durchs Dorf gejagt wird ne sondern da
irgendwas zu haben
und heute habe ich das heute habe ich
die Themen heute sehe ich die auch heute
weiß ich auch genau was mich da
interessiert aber ich habe lange lange
gebraucht weil einfach man sagt was
damals gelaufen ist vor vor 30 Jahren
das ist für uns unnachvollziehbar vom
vom
vom vom politischen Protest bis hin zum
zum bewaffneten Widerstand die das dass
die ganze Klaviatur wurde gespielt und
da steht man da und das ist glaube ich
auch einer der Gründe warum man unserer
Generation diese so eine
Politikverdrossenheit vorwirft
weil wir sind wir wir leben es ist so in
diesem Schatten und es ist so schwer aus
diesem übermächtigen Schatten
rauszutreten ne wenn man sagt was haben
was haben wir eigentlich gemacht was
machen wir eigentlich ne das war das war
eine wahnsinns eine eine wahnsinnskraft
ne
wir arbeiten uns dagegen so in den
Sphären von wie bringen wir das Studium
irgendwie zu Ende was machen wir danach
und wie passen wir uns dem Arbeitsmarkt
an ne das ist heute verständlich aber es
ist eben eine andere andere Grundhaltung
aus der dann auch kreativität entsteht
als früher aber es gibt doch zwei
riesige Themen wir müssen innerhalb von
10 Jahren eigentlich irgendwie den
Klimawandel in Griff kriegen wir haben
den Zusammenbruch des Finanzsystems es
gäbe doch Themen na klar die sind ja da
die sind ja da die mache ich ja auch die
natürlich das ist überhaupt keine Frage
es ist ja nicht so dass es keine Themen
gibt das ist nicht der Punkt die Frage
ist wie entwickelt man eine Haltung zu
diesem ne und wie entsteht Haltung ne
und wie wie wie entwickelt man die und
wie wie kommt man selbst erstmal zu
einer Haltung bevor man sie dann
sozusagen in Komik übersetzen kann ne
das ist ja sozusagen das ist ja der
Prozess der vorher stattfinden muss und
heute habe ich das über die Zeit einfach
gelernt und
und merke dann auch wie ich mich je
länger ich in dem Bereich arbeite mich
umso mehr Themen auch öffne die mich
dann auch interessieren und mir die dann
auch so zurechtlegen kan dass ich sie
humoristisch verarbeiten kann aber das
ist eben ein ein Prozess dahinzukommen
liegt das an der ich sag mal fehlenden
Ideologie in Anführungszeichen dass man
keine die Ideologie gibt vor da ist das
ich muss ich habe die Ideologie ich muss
also die Haltung einnehmen ja
genau ja das ist einfach das ist wie
gesagt ich möchte Ideologie da nicht
verherrlichen ich glaube das sind schon
das ist schon zweiiniges Schwert damit
ins Leben zu starten wir haben es da
auch einfacher mal deswegen hat das
Kabarett ja unter Schröder das Problem
die SPD war in der Regierung was machen
wir jetzt ist genau so ist es und
plötzlich waren die da die man die man
immer wollte ne und heute eine
Opposition zu bilden oder so ist war
ganz schwer weil weil der der der
Kapitalismus einfach so funktioniert ähm
dass er sich ähm immer schon
ähm dass er alles letztlich sozusagen
unter seine Fittiche genommen hat was
irgendwie von außen kam ne das heißt
alles was irgendwann mal dagegen war ist
heute hat sich der der Kapitalismus
vereinnahmt ne irgendwelche Flower Power
wir fahren ans Ende der Welt
Individualreisen war vor 30 Jahren ganz
ungewöhnlich und boah die machen das und
heute ist es ein Programm ist es ein
geschäftsprogramm ne was TUI Neckermann
und Co im im im Angebot haben ne und das
macht natürlich auch schwer dagegen zu
sein das macht ganz schwer noch etwas zu
finden wo man wirklich draußen steht
ohne dass sozusagen die Krake des
Systems kommt und sagt stimmt da machen
wir gleich ein Geschäft raus ne so ist
das System so ist es einfach das kann
man bejammern aber es ist einfach so und
dadurch und dadurch ist es ist es
schwieriger geworden und heute ist man
eben ich glaube an dem auch für mich
auch reizvolleren Punkt als man mit
einer Ideologie jemals wäre nämlich dass
man eben sagen muss wir haben nicht mehr
sozusagen die die Porzellanschüssel und
die sieht so und so aus und da gibt's
nichts in Frage zu stellen sondern die
porzellanschlüssel ist zerschlagen ne
wir können eigentlich nur noch ganz
viele kleine ein teile finden angucken
und gucken was passt da noch wie
zusammen und wie können was
zusammenbauen oder können wir nichts
zusammenbauen aber wenigstens auf die
Teile
Hinweisen du hast es vorhin selber
gesagt du guckst ich sag mal Ausweg
ausweglose Situationen an du guckst DIN
wo es weh tut wie hie noch mal das
Fremdwort für die ausweglosen
Situationen aporin
aporin du beschäftigst dich also mit
Themen die wirklich ja schweren Konflikt
im Menschsein sage ich jetzt
mal bedeuten tut das nicht selber weh
oder ist der das Kabarett machen da das
Ventil das ist genau das Ventil das ist
das Ventil diese
ganze themenschwere und Schwere der
Überlegungen lustig zu machen weil am
Abend ist mein Anspruch auch der einer
Leichtigkeit bei aller ernsthäftigkeit
muss das
Ganze sehr sehr leicht daherkommen um
punktuell schwer zu werden aber ich
möchte nicht und ich kann auch nicht
zwei Stunden am Stück weltanklage machen
ich wärst du ansonsten ein schwermütiger
Nietzsche auf der Couch geworden das ist
natürlich ein großes Wort aber
ich glaube nein weil sonst wäre ich es
auch so geworden dann hätte ich den wäre
ich nie auf die Bühne gegangen dann
hätte ich nie den Humor als
Ausdrucksform gewählt dann hätte ich
philosophische Bücher geschrieben oder
Literatur verfasst schwere und und wer
zu skamp gegangen und gesagt möchtet ihr
es nicht drucken ne das wäre dann mein
Ausweg gewesen aber ich habe ja bewusst
den den der Rampensau gewählt den des
nach außen Gehens auch den der
Lustigkeit und der Leichtigkeit und auch
des Spaßes und des auch auch das Spaßes
um seiner selbstwillen das muss ja auch
stattfinden insofern glaube ich das
nicht weil wer ein ein
schwermütiger Mensch oder ein sch oder
ein Nietsche werden soll oder will der
wird das und der wird nicht Kabarettist
aber vielleicht auch verdanken dem
Umstand dass du dick und hässlich warst
natürlich ja absolut
ja also das das im Nachhinein bin ich
für die ganzen schwierigen Situationen
auch dankbar weil man man lernt daraus
und ohne die W wäre ich nicht das was
ich heute bin insofern das hütet mich
auch davor Menschen gegenüber böse zu
sein ne von von früher weil letztlich
danke ich Ihnen allen warst du mal in in
deren Haut ja und letztlich habe ich den
allen was zu verdanken die ich damals so
in der Schule die meine meine Mäppchen
und Schultaschen durch die Gegen
geworfen haben die ich da gehasst habe
und und bin ich heute letztlich dankbar
ne dafür dass sie das gemacht haben weil
was wäre ohne das aus mir geworden was
wäre gewesen wenn ich mit der Hypothek
eines geglückten Lebens in die
in eine bedingungslos geglückten Jugend
so es sie denn gibt ins Leben gestartet
wäre ne dann wäre ich vielleicht heute
bei der Bank und hätte schon
Geld verzockt dann müsste mein Leben
fürchten dann beenden wir das Gespräch
mit der ungewöhnlichen Erkenntnis dass
mobben auch was Gutes hat ja so kann man
sehen vielen Dank gerne